نحن حقًا قد امتدنا مهما كانت السيارات التي
أرسلتها لهم هنا ، كما يقول
مستشفى الولادة في غارة جوية ، كان هذا
استجابة روسيا لنداء عالمي
لوقف إطلاق النار لإجلاء مدينة يبلغ عدد
سكانها مليون شخص ، ألقيت قنبلة بجوار
مستشفى للولادة في ماريوبول ،
إنها المستشفى رقم ثلاثة
داخل عملية بحث محمومة عن ناجين ،
تقول التقارير المبكرة إن هناك أكثر
من عشرة مصابين ، وهي
نتيجة معجزة لمحاولة قتل جماعي
في مكان يجب أن تبدأ فيه الحياة ، كان العديد من
النساء والأطفال قد فروا بالفعل إلى
المخابئ تحت الأرض بعد أسبوع من
القصف الروسي
جدد رئيس أوكرانيا
مناشداته لحلف شمال الأطلسي لطرد روسيا من
سماء بلاده بعد الضربة الجوية على المستشفى ،
كل ما يفعله المحتلون
بماريوبول هو بالفعل أبعد من الفظائع.
كانت
أكثر نجاحًا ولكنها لا تزال محدودة للغاية
حول 700 امرأة معظمهن من النساء
تم نقل الأطفال والأطفال من Anagoda ، وهو
موقع أكبر مفاعل نووي في أوروبا ،
والذي استولت عليه روسيا مؤخرًا
، والمحلات فارغة ، ولا يوجد شيء ،
لا يوجد ما يكفي من الإمدادات الطبية ، نحن
متعبون نحتاج إلى تناولها والراحة
، قد يبدو الأمر غير عادي ، لكن هذه
هي  المحظوظون ، لقد هربوا من
ظل محطة طاقة نووية
وبقايا القوات الروسية ، لكن
بالمقارنة مع ما يعانيه الناس
في ماريا بول ، فإن
هذا حظ
سعيد لمتطوعي يوليا كارولان في مركز للاجئين
في زابوسيا تم إنشاؤه لاستقبال
الأشخاص الفارين  مسقط رأسها في ماريوبول
، إنها فارغة
كانت تنتظر أسبوعًا للحصول على أخبار من
منزل زوجها إيفجيني وابنتها ياسر
هذا الصباح ، تلقت مكالمة مختصرة ،
كيف حال
ابنتك ،
أخبرتني ابنتي أنها
تحبني بالطبع إنها تفعل ذلك
بالفعل
كما هي  على قيد الحياة
هي تفعل مثل كل الأطفال الذين يفعلون
الآن في ماريو بال ، لا يوجد طعام تقريبًا ، لا
مياه للشرب ، لا كهرباء ،
لقد كان سالب خمسة هذه الليلة
ليس لديهم هو  عند الحواف تجلس في
قبو بارد وبعض المعاطف تعيش عائلتها الصغيرة
في ملجأ من القنابل مع
مئات آخرين تقول إنهم
لا يمكنهم البقاء على قيد الحياة سوى أيام قليلة أخرى ،
ثم سيتعين عليهم الظهور
ربما لمواجهة المزيد من
سام كيلي سي إن إن زاباريزا